that's a nice-looking little car dude
I'd like to drive around don't call a
little car dude a little car don't baby
don't
oh man that's not man who don't don't
[ __ ] dude hey did your surf and turf
just keep talking like that you can get
the surf and the turf dude hey bro bro
I'm comfortable on my feet and I'm
comfortable on the ground sure gotta be
honest with you sure I've never opened
up with you can i okay so here's the
thing no I know I know
you know I box but you're not afraid of
my boxing now now hold on all [ __ ]
aside if I open up with my feet hold on
I know you like to talk about your
Taekwondo days listen to me look at me
listen I hope not with my feet like wand
oh yeah okay Taekwondo hey you have
Taekwondo - Taekwondo we get me what
ain't [ __ ] I will kick you know dude
tonight I know at your age when you when
you're a kid yeah losers I hate to be
shitty about it Lumis [ __ ] way okay
take your job
hey you don't you know why you did
Taekwondo why did you come into anything
else and I'd hate to be shitty I was a
wrestler I hate to be she rude I am
naturally know why you guys did
Taekwondo I cuz there's nothing else for
you dude my wheel kick knows this
Taekwondo back then Oh [ __ ] whiskey
don't drink right don't dream what's
going through your old whiskey dude bro
my back ache you have no answer for my
wheel kick you got no answer for listen
if you want move this when I close
distant you want to get you want surf
and turf you can get surf and turf I
will move this table and look drunk I
will move this table and I will [ __ ] you
up
I'm a little rusty last morning I'm so
I'm getting Matthew all your kicks
you got your [ __ ] shoes on I all
right dude - I'm telling you be what the
[ __ ] dude this is this is 23 years you
drink a lot man and what I am
hey but I'm kind of drunk and horny no
I'm not I'm just telling your Taekwondo
listen to me I hate and it's about time
I drank this is Cheryl
hey hey hey [ __ ] you know who signs up
you know signs are kids up for Taekwondo
Oh parents cuz they're careful anything
you know because you're coming out the
ground you better pull your chute right
now because the crowds coming fast pull
your chute are you sure dude
order the surf and turf cuz it's
Wednesday and they we got a special you
know the special is it's black and blue
baby it's black and blue I can deliver
black and blue dude my elbows I got a
lot of weapons that might dispose I'll
become leaner elbows ain't Taekwondo
that'd be more tired and you're more
tired
Oh doesn't exist you don't think I
[ __ ] study everything Jackson Jackson
smooth see ya say what's cute
say what call me Jackson smooth I don't
like where you're going with this it's
making me mad and I'm a man I'm a proud
man and what are you doing right now
what the [ __ ] are you doing right now
call me Jackson smooth and if you feel
froggy dude and like I said if you want
to order the surf and turf's
we're open for business are you
stretching enjoy a good whistle and you
got a good with everything better
he didn't come close to dying so let's
be very clear there all right dude we
almost lost letõs we'll get off dude you
keep clown Jay Leno order the surf and
turf and guess what Wednesday's is black
and blue play hey bro again watch your
[ __ ] tone Jackson because I am not in
the mood and I will meet you [ __ ]
halfway and keep you tre busy trail
occupy occupy which means very busy
in French okay you saw climbing up on my
shoes my tail QP you see the rock
climbing rope on my ops why those stupid
I will take that off and choke the [ __ ]
outta you'll try as I always say to my
opponents you'll try
hey hey Bubba hey hey papa why all you
got to do is call up the waiter you're
looking at him at Red Lobster order the
surf and fluff in turn and it comes
hey you're a comes hot a little afraid
of you right now that surf and turf
comes off yeah City hey hey hold on this
urban turf comes ready sizzling hot now
you're deep you're about five drinks hey
hey all you should be hey hold on that
serpent do you like the crab biscuits
they're great right yeah sure
that's the order here's the thing yeah
that servant turf comes sizzling hot
yeah so what would you what do you think
you're gonna what do you think you're
gonna do when we're standing toe-to-toe
see when I do this my Denzel Washington
yeah yeah let me see this because I'm
feeling hot oh yeah I don't want you
leech al enjoys what happens is I gotta
meet the challenge and you got skinny
legs my boy right we know that hey Brian
dude what order surfacer now you gonna
say is hey all you gotta say is I'll
take the surf and turf
Jackson smooth say those words say those
words say oh say I'll take the surf and
turf Jackson smooth and it's on don't
like me in talents is a man hey man
we're old man all I'm saying all you
have to do yeah if you want to get fed
today if you want to get fed all you
guys all you gotta do is say Brendan I
will have the surf and turf please and
thank you you ready drinks it Jackson
smooth do matrix amber I'm not being
real with you and the problem is my set
my reactions are a little dull yep so
sure so are my daddy daddy's
daddy's little daddy into tousled top
right now hey daddy what all you have to
do is say Jackson smooth
can I have the surf and turf and I'm
gonna come in sizzling hot because you
ordered it because you ordered it and
I'm here and I'm ready
hey Jack oh dude don't do it Brian dude
I've warned you and now you're drinking
water don't do it
Geoff getting over the surf and turf
I'll say the words right see the words
Jackson smooth can I have the surf and
turf
dude order the surf and turf I'm not
gonna do it unless you're the surf and
turf if you were in serve turf you're
gonna get it and second come [ __ ]
Sizzlin you've had you've you've had the
crab say the words it's like beetlejuice
say the words and I come [ __ ] in
flying hot and you know it's a nice dish
I want to order the surf yep and Smurf I
said Smurf I didn't say turn all right
nope I don't know surfing Smurf okay no
hook to it Brendan Brendan let's move on
okay that's cuz he's just a little too
drunk for the [ __ ] around not gonna
matter gets drunk and gets a little
worried some kind of a virus here I feel
pretty good
so again Papa if you're hungry all you
gotta say
Jackson smooth I want the surf and turf
yeah he's gonna come yeah and now it's
what are you gonna do it's buttered up
watching splattered up what say you know
what do it's sticky huh it gets sticky
oh yeah yeah yeah let me tell you
something right the only reason I'm not
[ __ ] fighting you right now sure is
because I have to be a little careful a
lot of neck is always a little iffy hey
how about this
surf and turf won't touch your net you
got a bunch of other joints I like to
get my hands on I'm not afraid of that
sure I'm not afraid that's right those
how's your knees how's your arm tells
you you're not getting to them
Oh how's the move on your shoulder yeah
shoulder problems yeah you do know I'm
fine
all right sort oflike the key pays yeah
hey sir turf I'll take him for a ride
I'll punch you sure dude
order the surfing [ __ ] I'm Tarek I know
you well yeah dude and I've ordered the
surf and rock you are red lob we'll just
say the words like you're making me
three times say it three times like
Beetlejuice and I'll play you want to
play I'm gonna I'm an arcade game
promise you have [ __ ] bottles and
you're deep you're a half bottle in
almost no what do you talk dude Chin's
had kiss you've had this I've had a ton
of whiskey next current event my bill
juice eight three times
oh well maybe I will sometimes people
have an unfortunate situation what's
going on it's like a guy who's a
great-looking tall handsome pulls out
his rod and it short just it's just
short thin short then I've had friends
I'm [ __ ] startled my hog so and they
show me some stupid video and I'm like
no that's I I will [ __ ] tower over
you right now you were sure dude war for
sure no make sure the fans are well ok
then you're not talking about your boy
here's what you do it see what you're
doing you just kind of flirting with the
idea of or in surf and turf or yes okay
good salad you talking about me take it
easy you are Oh
again order it dude take it easy all
right I'm just saying all right but take
it easy take it easy
all right all right dude for a second
that I've kind of felt it no I know and
you were worried about me saying that
you're your wiener
is it your it's well doc you don't act
all like like that you're fine so well
dude you solid in the bathroom right now
my lucky piece when it when he's perched
up when he's angry
there's a little bend to him and I like
that Ben come on I I don't I don't have
a curve now Baz he's working this is
working this way into anger he tends to
wake up with a little like you know what
I'm
whale shows you just the top of it's
just the tip you come out just shut up
the whales crest yeah your your piece of
the lamp and somehow the middle part
wakes up first
I got you got the middle part it's like
instruct you it's like your consent dear
what is my back first in this there you
go then he goes alright I'll come out of
the water and at first he's like I'm
gonna bring my move and we got a little
bed nothing wrong are you bad
yeah you're a fat dick it's well
document as well I tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]